Chinese President Xi Jinping has scolded
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
in what appears to be a hot
mic moment made for the world to see.
The cringeworthy 42nd long exchange
came on the sidelines of the G20
summit in Bali.
She appeared to be irritated
at the details
of an earlier conversation with
had been leaked to the Canadian
And that's not all the way
everything we discussed with the
leaked to the paper.
That's not appropriate.
There is no one in our team,
and that's not all the way
the conversation will never leav
And you're
for free and open and frank dial
And this woman will continue
to have
you will continue
to look to work constructively t
But there will be things we will
disagree on. You know,
that's all about how you
must create the conditions first
And done.
Earlier this week, the two leade
their first face to face convers
in more than three years.
Trudeau reportedly raised
serious concerns over China's
domestic interference,
including allegations
China meddled in Canada's 2019 e
For all this,
joined by CNN's Will
Ripley in Bangkok, Thailand.
So will you.
Xi Jinping, he's
no stranger being on the world s
He knows where the cameras are
in this dressing gown.
Trudeau was done
knowing it would be
seen around the world.
What a humiliation it was.
It is certainly remarkable
considering just how buttoned up
and how carefully control
the state media is in China,
which, of course, is
not showing this exchange.
And yet,
this this back and forth where X
is basically putting on display
this muscular style of face
to face diplomacy
that has been so lacking in rece
because he's been hunkered down
in the mainland in Beijing,
doing virtual summits and avoidi
face to face contact.
Now he's out in the global stage
He was in Bali.
He's on his way here to Bangkok.
He'll be landing within the next
And there's no mask on,
despite zero
COVID in China,
where people in Beijing are bein
to wear masks all the time.
He's shaking hands
and he's getting right
up in the faces of,
you know,
some of the most important
allies of the United States
after that
three hour meeting on Monday
with President Biden,
which was an attempt to if not a
It certainly,
you know,
sit down and have a discussion
and be very be clear,
have clarity
about about the mutual goals of
and the United States.
He then went on to meet with oth
allies, Australia, France,
the Netherlands, South Africa.
Australia was a big meeting.
They've had a very tense relatio
in recent years. There have been
There have been
there's been increasing
tension over a myriad of issues,
but basically went back to Austr
calling for an investigation
into the origins of COVID 19
And now you have
this kind of informal discussion
with Justin Trudeau, where Xi Ji
with that swagger
of somebody
who's basically been bestowed
the title of Emperor for life.
You know, he
he essentially now has unchecked
inside China.
He he showed the world in those
exactly
that he now
is wielding the strength
in these face to face meetings.
So listen to what
Justin Trudeau,
the prime minister of Canada,
had to say after that exchange.
Equity response.
Listen.
I think that people know that
not all
the conversations are going to b
with the other leaders,
especially when it comes to issu
that are sources of disagreement
One thing that President Biden
has basically kind of created
this narrative over the last few
that Xi Jinping has been absent
from these face to face meetings
is that there is this this globa
you know,
escalating conflict,
if you will, between the free wo
and the autocratic world.
But Xi
Jinping push back on that,
calling his style of governance,
where essentially
he has an echo chamber of yes ma
allowing him to move forward
with any of his objectives
with virtually unchecked power.
He calls that Chinese style demo